what's up everyone welcome back for
another san diego comic-con 2022
interview i have the team behind one of
my favorite shows out there right now
with us and it is what we do in the
shadows
emmy nomination galore season renewal
galore you deserve it congratulations
thank you
thank you perry you are very very
welcome all right paul i'm coming your
way first
when you first got the go-ahead for
season one of this show did you have a
road map for what you wanted the series
to look like and then is there anything
about your experience making seasons one
through four that has changed that road
map since no i mean there was no road
map beyond the season that we were doing
and there never has been we sort of use
everything we have in our minds at the
time for on the current season and then
usually end on something that's a
cliffhanger and and decide we'll figure
it out when we come back and start on
another season but there's everything
that's come up has been sort of
come up because some something happened
earlier that we had to deal with you
know that process is working for you
keep it up so you end season three what
is the biggest difference between the
ideas you had for season four and what
the season turned out to be i think uh
probably just
no ideas changed the difficulty of doing
baby calling was
was something that if we'd known
beforehand i think we still would have
charged ahead and done it but uh we
would have had a little more humility
about how difficult it was to do that
mark at what point did you find out
about baby colin did you actually did
you have any idea for where the
character could go when you were first
told about where season three would end
for him
yeah paul mercifully filled me in on uh
what season four was going to look like
um
around close towards the end mid-season
i guess or no it actually was after the
table read where i die
he then
remembered to let me know that i'm not
fired um
which was you know a couple hours after
the table read
um but i i knew it was
they had something fun planned so it is
it's very fun it's something that i
never could have expected and i imagine
it is a massive production challenge so
mark for you what is something that has
proven to be an incredible creative
challenge but then on the other hand
what is something about a process like
that that's surprisingly creatively
fulfilling for you
well the the challenge definitely was
figuring out what colin robinson
what he
how he acts at the each stage of his
development
because throughout the season you see
him go through the different stages of
development very quickly
and how does colin respond to that not
how do how would i play colin
as an adult which is kind of you know
he's annoying and sarcastic and dry
how does that translate into the child
um
that was
a process that i had to go through
and figuring out and then
um
what was fulfilling is just being able
the exact same thing
being able to breathe new life into this
character um
was has really been a gift um
to me um you can get a little um
tired of sucking energy all the time um
and you don't want the character to
actually be annoying
um are you tired of it right now no no
and so
so
that was fun
[Laughter]
jerks
you don't get creative opportunities
like that very often and you guys are
totally making the most of that i'm
gonna throw that question to you too
matt so onset given laszlo's
relationship with baby colin what is
something i've just got to clear
something up first let's hear him he
wasn't in canada for the whole of the
fourth season he was on his
backside um
yeah it was
it was difficult
but it was
some of the craziest stuff i've ever
done
um
there's some things that i don't know
have
have gone out yet because the dog food
stuff gone out yet yes people have seen
stuff like that
you never i'll never get to do that
again
or see anything like that again what is
the most difficult part of the
production process of acting opposite
baby colin try not to frighten anyone i
think
because you have kids on set right well
there's that then there's chainsaws on
set there's all kinds of things that
yeah
yeah it's a combination of kids and just
dangerous
water loose electrical wires chainsaws
all that stuff it's uh would make anyone
anxious all right feels show appropriate
though um
for laszlo he has been alive for a real
real long time but when someone has the
opportunity to raise a child that could
change them forever so is this the most
life-changing thing he has ever been
through it's the most important thing
that he's ever done i think everything
up until that point has been for his own
you know sort of pleasure and for him
and this is the first time you know when
he's actually spent his days thinking
about someone else apart from himself
does this kind of confirm the uh the
origin of the energy vampire or is there
more to discover there is it kind of
like a serpent eating its tail type
thing there's much more to discover and
we will discover it okay and we will
share it with you and with the viewers
at a time that is appropriate
i look forward to that i'm okay with
preserving some mystery
harvey for you one thing that i have
always wondered since day one of this
show is do you ever think that he's
gonna hit a point where
he gets over the idea of needing to
become a vampire and if so what would it
take
no i don't think he has gotten to that
point every time he gets discouraged by
seeing how
the familiars like i'm thinking of benji
and like how he never became a vampire
and he was hypnotized to forget
everything and um
seeing how things are not working out
the way he planned he's taking matters
into his own hands and so sometimes you
can get what you want it's just a
different route and so maybe that's
going to be the case or maybe he gives
up on it but i feel like he's never
going to want to not not want to be a
vampire i think he has like a great
backstory of why he wanted to do that
they're so fabulous they get to wear
these beautiful clothes they live
forever they're young they feast they
f and then they do whatever they want
and so i think he wants to live a life
that's carefree like that uh so he will
always want to be that in that case if
he will always still want to be a
vampire how has his like dream version
of himself being a vampire changed from
season one to now given what he's
experienced thus far he's seen by trial
and error what you what you should do
with uh with great power because great
responsibility or you can just throw it
out the window but he takes from every
one of the vampires i feel like he he
likes certain elements of each one of
them he admires them for different
qualities that they each present and and
maybe at the at the end makes for the
ultimate vampire i like i want him to
get what he
wants and foremost i want guillermo to
be happy and i think this season i don't
know paul would you agree it's like he
goes down that what he wants or do you
want him to be happy that's the question
well there's that's the question isn't
it and if what if what you want makes
you happy or is will it make you happy
that's the bigger question so i don't
know about getting what you want makes
you happy but will it make you happy to
get what you want
[Laughter]
so we'll have to see
kristen with your character i have
always wondered
what what if there was no one higher
than her on the food chain what if no
one was above her on the pay scale how
would she run the vampiric council if
she had the opportunity to do everything
the way she wanted
well i think before
these guys uh
joined and like usurped her i think she
was doing it very adequately and you
know correct i think she was very good
at her job so i think she would just
keep doing it
but she needs some self-confidence you
know i like she should be i know that
was a punishment for her but i feel like
like when nadja got invited to go to the
vampiric council in london i was pissed
like
what you know i said but i don't think
the guide would stick up for herself so
she needs to get a little more of a
backbone before she could um do things
uh
better
okay great i kind of want to see that
how about those costumes
but re but really when you go into uh
nightclub mode that's true the car i
feel like that you're pretty electric a
guide and nodule this season in the
nightclub the the the costume department
really did a great job or a montgomery
yeah of having them have this this look
that was you know
banging vampires after dark if i'm like
yes
and the wigs too the wig was fun our wig
our wig our head hair person
um what's her name again tomorrow yeah
she is incredible she's like dealing
with wigs not just for
nausea
and myself but then she's also dealing
with wigs for as we'll see in this
episode tomorrow all these different
characters from all these different
worlds and just to keep everything
everybody that works on this show is is
really talented who's the energy vampire
tomorrow's episode is night market right
this is coming out after that so feel
free to spoil that episode which is
incredible
thank you so you've seen it yes i have
seen it and there's some incredible set
design in that i want to get into that
but because you guys have name dropped a
whole bunch of people who work on this
show beyond the faces that we see often
if you could name an unsung hero of this
production someone that we don't see or
talk about often but really contributes
in a big way that significantly impacts
your work who would you name drop now
and why boy it's so hard to narrow it
down i would i would start with uh our
directors jana gorskaya and kyle
newechuk our main directors and jana
also has edited the show from the very
beginning and also edit edited the movie
um but the two of them bring an extra
i don't know what it is to it but it has
to be honor yeah yeah oh can i say it
too and i don't know their names but the
the
camera operators are obviously like part
of the show like they're narrating it
for the home viewers and they're so
skilled at this point like they're
always a step ahead and knowing where to
be
it's a it's a it's next level
whatever their names are i don't know
it looks like cameras to me they're like
family tests
is there anything about the process of
working with those camera operators that
has evolved as you've kind of perce
as you've kind of perfected the process
from season one to now i i mean i feel
like it's difficult because they have to
pretend to be documentary
they have to know as camera operators
what's going to happen in the scene but
they have to pretend that they don't
know what's going to happen and if
someone talks they pan over to that
person they have to make it look like
it's happening very spontaneously and
it's a hard thing to do and there
were times there was a learning curve
early on in the show where people would
go like oh i know that guy's going to
talk next i point there but a
documentary would never do that so it
really is a much higher degree of
difficulty for our camera operators
going back to the night market episode
those are some exceptional sets really
all of your sets have a wild amount of
detail but for the night market stuff in
particular can each of you pinpoint like
a teeny tiny little detail that maybe
isn't highly focused on in a frame but
like really speaks to the environment
that you hope people catch in the night
market well shane fox our production
designer uh did that set and it was
amazing and expensive that it's our most
ambitious episode yet the part i keep
thinking about is there's a part in the
beginning where they're walking through
and
there's a woman who's selling bird cages
who's also wearing a bird cage over her
head sort of like a helmet and it was
none of that is stuff that's scripted in
the script we go they go to a night
market they meet all sorts of
supernatural creatures and then all the
various departments the prosthetics
people go like we could have a little
weird shoe shine guy what if we had this
one with the bird cage so that's really
an example of the collaboration that
goes on between everyone who works works
up there and it just resulted in an
episode that's like
bigger than anything i think we ever
thought we would do
it's something else anyone else have a
detail they want to share i like the
cars that we got to play on to jump on
they're like classic 70s yeah and
late uh sixties uh cars that we got to
jump and do stunts on and play off of
that and that whole area was really fun
and like falling through uh the trailer
and and the upstairs where they were
welding it was like sparkles and all
that that's life that's always fun to
have on set like you kick all the ass in
that scene i love it so like i know you
have done stunts in the show before but
was that the uh the highest bar of stunt
work you've done thus far that was our
biggest stunt i think to date that was
uh and uh who's our stunt director and
who's actually directed a couple of
episodes um he's great like uh it was a
lot it was like moving parts to
everything and nandor and guillermo
fighting and there's real swords
involved and running upstairs and all of
that and flying and we introduced new
skills for guillermo that he picked up
overseas perhaps the with actual stick
and all that yeah how much have you
filled in the blanks in terms of the
time that lapses between season three
and season four in terms of what he was
up to over there well that's what's
really cool that since we never see the
documentary crew follow them and to go
over to
london or the uk and watch them do
anything we can say you know he what was
he doing for a year he met somebody he
picked up some skills he perfected some
of the old skills that he had and
he came back to staten island with them
so that's the great part that we can
actually
say he might have done that one of my
absolute favorite things to ask about in
general is the value of a good scene
partner and in this show it feels like
it's of the utmost importance given how
much you play off of each other and how
pitch perfect the comedic timing always
is so can each of you give me an example
of a time when a seam partner was just
what you needed and helped you bring
something out of your own performance
that you wouldn't have been able to get
to without them
[ __ ] that's a hard one i mean i'm not
even one of you guys i i i
i'll jump in and say that my favorite
scenes in the show is when it has
everyone all the characters together in
one room all talking at once those are
my favorite scenes and that often when
riders pitch in ideas a lot of people
say
nandor goes off and does this laszlo
goes off and does this with some new
different character i'm always like it's
always better if there's at least two of
our regular characters there you know
what i mean there's something about the
the chemistry that just makes those
scenes
great
saying that though sorry yeah i know
what i'm gonna say was i did a scene um
with tony who plays the neighbor
and
improvised a bit where i kind of lunged
to sort of kiss him
and he didn't know that that was gonna
happen and um
the way that he dealt with that was
amazing
and it's in there i think you know yeah
it is pretty much what we did
and i get to do scenes obviously with
kvon all the time and he's the best and
great as a scene partner because he's so
giving it's also nice to go and do
scenes with other other cast mates that
we usually don't do scenes like this
year we have kristin and i doing scenes
together when she's lusting over
guillermo which is really fun to play
and it brings a different vibe because
it's a different character obviously and
then uh matt and i got to co-parent this
season some and uh seeing that dynamic
between the characters was fun and
people the fan base seemed to like that
a lot and and shipped that also a lot of
it where we're writing is we're thinking
of who have we who haven't we seen
together yet which
ended up with one of my favorite like
stories and scenes of the season which
was when
laszlo is psychoanalyzing the guide to
figure out
what her past is because i realized we
hadn't had many scenes that were just
laszlo in the guide and uh it's some of
my favorite stuff uh in the whole whole
season kristen mark how about for uh you
too a time when a scene partner made all
the difference for you
i don't know how much we can talk about
what's coming up and what we haven't
revealed yet but i say you could talk
about everything you want
um there are some interactions i have
with
you know
children and
being able to then act off of
their energy
was allowed me then to i think hone in
on the child character a little better
yeah i will say
one of my favorite things about this
show and i'm not gonna pick a specific
person or scene but every single person
on this show
is so good and so funny and so quick
and ready to improvise it is the biggest
gift to be able to play on this show
with each and every one of the cast i
would believe it i feel like a show like
this can't be as successful as it is
without that particular quality before i
let you guys go i'm going to squeeze in
one unrelated question for you i'm sure
you've been getting a lot of blue beetle
questions while you're here but the main
reason i want to ask is because i'm a
massive fan of show lows and i've seen
him grow over the course of making cobra
kai and i'm just so excited to see him
headline a big movie like that so what
is it about him on that set that you
know says to you that he is a really
strong number one that's to make a
really unique superhero and also just
have a great influence on that gigantic
company in production charlo is the
perfect blue beeto he is the perfect
person to be cast in that we celebrate
his 21st birthday on said he's the
kindest super talented and willing to go
the extra mile to make the scene work
and it's it's a great script and we're
excited for next summer
you got that in your back pocket didn't
ya
but he is wonderful i'm so happy for him
i'm happy for you
huge congratulations on everything
you've accomplished with this show thus
far it brings so much light and joy into
my life so thank you thank you to
everybody out there like you're
obviously binging this show but just in
case if you're not you're missing out
get on it go watch what we do in the
shadows right now